- Hello Class of 2020.
These past couple of
months I, like most of you,
have found myself feeling
nostalgic for all the moments
that have made my time
at Yale feel so special.
But as comforting as
it can be to reminisce,
we must also open our hearts
and minds to what lies ahead,
and today we get to do both.
We, on the Class Day Committee,
are very excited to share
with you the Class History slide show,
a compilation of photos
submitted by all of you
commemorating our journeys
as undergraduates.
But before we start cringing
at pictures from Yale Up,
I have the honor of
introducing Dean Marvin Chun,
who will offer insight into
our individual and collective
futures as the unique class of 2020.
- Class of 2020, congratulations.
I am so happy to be with
you today, even by video,
and to celebrate with you.
Graduating is a great
accomplishment, one of the most
important ones of your life.
And now that this moment has finally come,
I am honored to recognize it with you.
I also recognize all the
work that you have done
to get you here, much
of it with the support
of your family and friends.
Today is your day and it is theirs too.
Over the past week, together
with you, I've enjoyed
watching this series of Class Day videos.
Tomorrow there will be a toast
to the Yale Class of 2020,
like what many of you have celebrated
in your residential colleges.
On Sunday, I'm excited
for our Class Day speaker,
Dr. Jean Bennett, a world-renowned
scientist and alumna.
Also this Sunday, prizes will be announced
on the Yale2020 website.
I'm grateful to the Class Day
Committee and to the speakers
who all contributed to this
Class Week series of videos.
And I'm most appreciative
to you, especially now,
during senior week.
I miss seeing you on campus,
and I can't wait to welcome you
back to campus in due time.
We've already started
planning all the parties
and ceremonies that we will
host for you and your families.
So until we meet in person,
please stay safe and well.
Again, Class of 2020, congratulations.
- Thank you, Dean Chun,
for your encouraging words.
And now let's take a moment
to look back at some of your
favorite memories from the past few years.
Please enjoy the Class History slide show.
(upbeat music)
- All right, so first question.
How would you describe
yourself as a first year?
- Oh boy.
(upbeat music)
- I was too confident.
- Naive, but well-intentioned.
- I was really eager to see
what Yale had in store for me
for the next four years, but
I had no idea just how much
that would be.
- I'd say that I was a
little academically intense.
- I was definitely extremely
caffeinated, probably,
at any given moment.
- I was energetic, enthusiastic,
ready to just dive in.
- I was always super
excited about everything,
but also a little lost
and confused constantly.
- How'd I overcome sophomore slump?
I didn't really.
- Did I overcome sophomore slump?
- Does anyone truly
overcome sophomore slump?
- Yeah, I don't know if I did either.
- Hit that and just went down from there.
- Yale started to feel like
home when Ellie Odroit,
Lauren Telesz, Sam Issick,
and I committed to having
breakfast together every day.
- When I really bought
into the Saybrook Community.
- I moved into my residential
college and really got
to know my suite and it
started feeling like a family.
- We threw our huge Christmas party.
- I was on the phone
with my mom and she asked
where I was going, and
I said I was going home,
but I didn't mean to Texas.
I was just like walking
from the grocery store
back to my apartment in New Haven.
- The last day of my first
year, when I had to say goodbye
to my roommate and I was
like, we need to suck in,
this is all over.
- My favorite first event.
Freshman Olympics on Old Campus.
(laughs)
- Definitely my first Spring Fling.
We did have good Spring Fling performers.
- Harvard - Yale game.
- Harvard - Yale for sure.
- Harvard - Yale.
- Harvard - Yale was
unbelievably life-changing.
- We won after having a
really long losing streak,
and no one thought it was going to happen.
It was so unexpected and
I'll never forget the last
few minutes of that game
ticking down when we realized
what was happening, and
everyone storms the field
at the end.
(crowd cheers)
- The community that has been
most impactful on me at Yale
has definitely been the Morse's Community.
- Thai City and Sphinx, and Saybrook too.
- The Acapella community
and more specifically,
Mixed Company and the Whiffs.
- Aurelian Honor Society, my
secret society has definitely
been there for me.
- Pearson College and the
Yale Ballroom Dance Team,
of which I'm a proud member.
- I think we both have the
same answer for this one.
- Yeah, we do.
- It's probably the Dramat.
- Definitely Dukes of Yale.
Hands down.
Dukes.
- [Girl] My favorite
memory is on Old Campus
when it turned spring and
everyone emerges from their dorms
to picnic, that is the best,
like the first sunny day
on Old Campus.
- It was just beautiful weather
and Isaac's gonna be full,
so a few, a couple of more,
Mark Rosenberg, Camille Beckford
and myself threw around a
Frisbee, kinda for the first time
since freshman year.
- My friend, Sophia Zafurco,
she was doing office hours
on Old Campus, which she
just like would sit outside
and play guitar and sing.
- I lived in Bingham, which was awesome,
but also I love being so
close to Harkness Tower
and hot tink, I loved hearing
the bells ring every morning.
- I have a lot of memories
of just sitting outside
on the germ-free benches
for hours just talking
to whoever passed by.
- Just sitting down next to
someone that you don't know
on a bench and introducing
yourself and just kind of that
mingling of people from
all different colleges.
I made some friends that
lasted four years that way.
- Something that surprised
me about Yale, honestly,
is just how quickly the years went by.
I can't believe like we're
graduating right now.
- Probably just how much
freedom Yale gives you.
You can really kinda do whatever you want
with your Yale experience,
and the professors,
the faculty will be there
to support you through it.
- Anyone would help you if you asked.
And I think that's something
that's really special.
- Honestly, how nice people are.
Like I feel like that's
something that we people just say
all the time, like people
at Yale are so nice,
but it's really true.
- Time is so short when
you're at Yale because there's
just so much to do.
There's a balance, but you
know, I wouldn't have had it
any other way.
(upbeat music)
- My favorite ice cream
spot on campus, Arethusa.
- Arethusa.
- Definitely Arethusa.
- Arethusa, favorite
ice cream spot, easily.
- Agreed.
- Arethusa, butter pecan in a waffle cone.
- It was Ashley's for a long
time, but now it's Milk Craft.
- Ashley's, gotta get the Frisbee.
- Ashley's has the best
variety of flavors,
but if you want richness and
creaminess, go to Arethusa.
- Favorite Yale dining dish.
Gotta be the grilled cheese.
The grilled cheese slaps.
- I always go tenders.
- [Girl] Chicken parm.
- [Woman] If there are
multigrain pancakes on the menu,
I will wake up just for those.
- Finnish pancakes, and they're so good.
I gotta learn how to make them.
- The stand-outs for me are always
in the dessert department.
- Olive oil, pear, cardamom cake.
I didn't even know olive oil
could be put in desserts,
but it is the best thing I've ever eaten.
People are sleeping on this dessert.
I've already made it like
three times in quarantine.
It turned out terribly all three times,
and I really wish that I could
have just one more slice.
- Favorite coffee shop?
Either Jojo's for the
honey lemon ginger tea,
or Book Traders for studying.
- Definitely Blue State on York.
- The Acorn in Silliman College.
- Atticus, JoJo's, and Koffee? with a K.
- Fussy Coffee, hands down.
- Probably Willoughby's.
Willoughby's does it right.
- Book Trader Cafe, the egg
and cheese changed my life.
- Koffee? with a K, because
they have really good lemonade
and I like lemonade.
- Favorite New Haven restaurant?
New Haven has a ton of
fantastic restaurants.
- Rubamba or Zirafas.
- Taste of China.
- Rubamba or Olea.
- Unias, specifically because
of the midnight grommet.
- [Girl] Metro Noodle Bar.
- [Woman] Metro Noodle Bar.
- I think Barcelona wins.
- I love Yorkside.
- If we're talking two
o'clock on a Friday,
then probably Halal Guys
always hits the spot for me.
- The best study spot for
me is actually in my bed.
- If you are staying up late,
is the Pearson Dining Hall.
- Music library.
- Murray Library.
- An STI room with the
fireplace, where you can just
put your feet up, read
a book next to the fire,
look out the window.
- In the Acorn on the study desks.
(guitar music)
- Biggest mentors at Yale.
Oh my God.
- That's a big question.
- JT, Professor Raymond, Tracy
from the Good Life Center,
and Sissy from the Yale College office.
- Certainly the theater mentors.
Actor Matt mentors for sure.
- Reverend Jenny Peak,
out here helping people navigate
queerness and Christianity
all the time.
- The actual like senior students
in the student club, Yale Launch.
They had founded their own company
and they were really big mentors for me.
Not only in the entrepreneurship process,
but just growing as a person
to really believe in myself.
- Dan Egan, this man is incredibly
empowering and dedicated,
and inspiring, and Jenny Tsori,
just a mind-boggling
endless well of wisdom
and depth and humanity.
- Now that I'm in quarantine,
one thing I realized
I took for granted are the
events and activities at Yale.
- Two things: the first
one is just the beauty
of the campus itself, yeah, the buildings.
And the second one is all the
people and how I could just
bop around from common room to common room
and hang out with everyone.
I'm really missing everyone right now.
- [Guy] The energy of walking
around and having people
that you can just run into
on the street and have
a conversation with is
something that I've really
taken for granted.
- Just the simple joy of
walking place to place
and seeing people you know
passing by while you're walking
across Old Campus, across
campus, or up Hill House.
- Just being able to
run into anyone's rooms
and see what friends are
around and wanna hang out.
- What's something you
wish you would've done
before leaving campus?
I wish I walked up Hill
House one last time.
- I wish my band could've
played one more time.
I'm a singer-songwriter and I
just started performing live
this year and we thankfully
got to perform at Cafe Nine
at the end of January
and that was very nice.
- One last swing on the
Berkley North Court tire swing.
- Going to Da Legna's Pizza
because I heard that it
was amazing and I had made
plans to go after Spring Break
and I never made it there.
But I will make it there one day.
- I wish that I would've
had more of a real chance
to say bye to all my best friends.
I wish that we could've given
each other our last hugs,
had those last meaningful
conversations in person.
- I wish I would've had one
more late night conversation
with my suite.
I think we had a lot of
those and they would last
really long and they were so
fun and I wish we could've
had one more.
- I wish I could just
remember and say goodbye
to like one last normal day.
Doesn't even have to be a perfect day,
just like one last normal day.
(upbeat music)
- I think the most important
thing that I've learned at Yale
is just the variety and
the ways that people like
live their lives and how they've
gotten to where they are.
- I've just learned about so
many different ways of life.
- How to deal with really
unbelievably difficult times,
at least the ones I've faced so far.
It's taught me grit.
- How to prioritize my
relationships and how to really
be there for my friends.
- How to stop procrastinating.
I just became a lot better at
doing things ahead of time.
- Just do your best.
Don't compare yourself to
others and just take pride
in your own accomplishments.
- I wanna say thank you to my suite,
to all of Pearson College, to
the Yale Ballroom Dance team,
for really giving me a home at Yale.
- Thank you to Sinim for
being the absolute best
senior year roommate.
You were there for me in my lows.
You celebrated with me in my highs.
I'm so grateful to you, so thank you.
- Thank you to the Whiffenpoofs
for making me a part
of the Class of 2020.
It's great.
- Thank you to the Class of
2019 and the Class of 2020
for being my original and
current communities at Yale.
- I would like to thank
Yale for pushing me outside
my comfort zone and really
challenging me to think
about what is it that
I'm passionate about.
- Thank you to Professor
Chewess for taking the time
to help me understand
so many different things
that I hadn't known before
about the communities and really
just giving her all for
every single student she has.
- Thank you to Professor
Tracy, who taught my
Writing for Television class
for teaching my favorite class
that I've ever taken at Yale
and making me realize as I went
through the semester that
I would love to end up
in television at some point.
- Thank you to all my friends
for the endless memories
that we made.
I miss you guys all so
much, and thank you to Yale
for my bright college years.
We almost made it to four.
- Thank you to Yale for everything.
(upbeat music)